[音楽]
me
[拍手]
始めぬ夫婦して聞いてください
てろ過激派武装組織に京都を殺す野蛮な人たち
不自由で虐げられた女性たち
音を開けてください
皆さんが見たイメージは
黒旗を掲げ武器を持って覆面姿の医者の京都でしたか
それとも全身を包んだあ俺な女性でしたか
それは皆さんが実際に体験して
目にしてきたイスラムの世界でしょうかそれともメディアを通じて見えた世界でしょう
か
皆さんは私を見て何を感じているのでしょうか
私と初めて接する方ノーカー私を日本人とさえ思いません
日本語がお上手ですねなんで日本に住んでいるんですか
ご出身はどちらあっ
私は日本人ですと答えます
するとじゃあこのスカーフはご主人の国
あれ宗教ですよね
と聞かれます
th
ちょっと違います
ここから会は弾みます
私はこの店先や待合室で始まる立ち話をいつも楽しんでいます
なぜならスカーフをかぶっているから外国人に違いないとか
結婚して夫の宗教に従っているからと思っている方も私に興味を持って話しかけてきて
くれたことがとてもうれしいからです
私は
イスラム教徒になりましたそして通して自分の意思で1シャム京都になったのか
そして日本人としてみたいスタムの世界を今日は皆さんにお話ししたいと思います
まず今世界には16億人のイスラム教徒がいると言われています
このイスラム人口は
増加率73%というレートで増え続け今世紀半ば
2050年には28億人に達すると言われています
これは世界人口の30%つまり3人に1人がイスラム教徒という試算です
この背景には
イスラム系に若い世代が多く高い出生率を保持しているからという理由だけではあり
ません
無宗教だったものや他の宗教からイスラムに入信するという人口が増えているという
背景も試算されているのです
かつて私も
神仏拝む典型的な日本人でした
しかし今はイスラム教徒です
このイメージの悪い宗教のどこに
人を惹きつける魅力があるのでしょうか
私の人生を変える友人と出会ったのは私がアメリカのオレゴン州に留学して1年が経っ
た頃でした
自由の国アメリカ様々な価値観に触れ
ようやく私は好きなように切れるのだと思っていたはずなのに
なぜか空虚で迷いの多い日々
そんな時私が出会ったのは
飛び級で16歳で大学に入学してくる
そんな賢いアメリカ人のつ女の子でした
ただ彼女は頭にスカーフをかぶっていました
真夏だというのになぜでしょ
私は聞きました
すると彼女は自分が一切の京都だと教えてくれ
なぜ使う方かぶっているのかなぜ全身を隠す服を着ているのか
年頃だというのにデートやパーティーに行かないのはなぜか
それは彼女が入っセムの教えを守っているからだと言いました
私は最初彼女に同情しました
なんてかはいそうな子
友人として付き合って家
彼女の聡明さ
善悪に対する明快な姿勢
圧倒的な優しさと懐の深さに私は心から感動したのです
してい
私は
彼女のように生きてみたい彼女のような生き方がしてみたいと思うようになったのです
私は以前から宗教に対する不信感を持っていて
イスラム教に対しても漠然とした不安な気持ちを持っていました
ただ彼女と付き合って
私はよく知りもせずに
ネガティブなイメージで彼女の宗教を見ているのではないかと気がついたのです
そこで一度心にセットしてい
イスラムについて彼女の信仰について調べることにしたのです
調べれば調べるほど目からウロコのことばかり
いっ
私がそれまで思っていた一緒の世界が180度ひっくり返りました
世界を見る目が
急に明るくなった気がしました
真実を知って心が揺さぶられるそんな経験を私は何度も繰り返しました
そして私は決意したのです
人種や時代や国
そういったものに関係なく
生涯変わることがない
人生の指針
そのイスラムの効かと私は選ぼうと思ったのです
24才の時でした
皆さんにとってイスラム外国の遠い国の宗教でしょうか
皆さんがもし
身辺を清潔に保ち落ちているゴミを拾ってゴミ箱に捨てたり両親や年調査に対して病の
気持ちを持って困ってる人を助けたことがあるならば
それはイスラムの生き方を実践していると言えます
私はいスタッフについて学び始めたとき
武と日本人の精神性に多くの共通点を見出しました
例えば
謙虚
公庫
0ギー
平日
これらは皆イスラムの美徳ですでもまるで武士道です
そして
皆さんが皆持っているものだと思います
一シャム柿方は異世界なものではなく
皆さんの日常の道徳観と日本古来の美徳の延長線上にあるのです
東日本大震災が起きたとき日本中世界中から多くの被災地支援が集まりました
そして東京のモスクでも
震災後すぐに
炊き出しの支援を呼びかけを行い地元商店街の人たちと協力をして
500個のおにぎりと支援物資を持って翌日には現地へ向かったのです
この活動は100回以上も継続され
中学校の社会科の教科書に紹介されるまでになりました
イスラムでは宗教や人種に関係なく困っている人を助けると教えています
なぜだーらー
見た目や出身や言葉や国が違っても私たちを同じ人間です
同じ心を持っていますだからみんなと一緒に助け合う
当然のことなのです
いすたむは
女性について何と言ってるでしょうか
教育を受けれなかったり結婚の自由がなかったり
差別されたり
それは
事実と全く異なります
実際はその真逆なのです
私はイスラム教徒として女性としてのびのびと生きていると感じています
いっそ m には女性の美しさや尊厳を社会全体で大切にする仕組みがあるのです
例えば
女性の日美しさそれは公に人目に晒すのではなく
たおやかに包み込み
自分のものとしてそして自分の家族のものとして大切にするのです
セクシュアル1
性的魅力女性の身体とても異性にとって魅力的だと思います
ただそれを不特定多数の異性に対して機能させるのではなく
特別な関係にある伊勢つまり待遇者と自分との関係において機能させる
それがいすたむの仕組みなのです
私は行っサムの中に
ピース平安を乱しています
男と女の違いを公平に認め
寮生の役割
男女が自然
機能するお互いに助け合う仕組みを持っている
そんなイスラムの姿に私は安心感を感じています
ただ
イスラム圏の女性が抑圧されている
差別されているといった状況もあるのです
ただそれが入っさんの教えかといえばそうではありません
その土地の風土や教育の欠如
文化がそうさせているというのです
では
イスラムとテロの関係についてはどうでしょうか
これはイメージだと思います
90年代の中頃
日本ではオウム真理教が日本人の若者を1万人も取り込み
数々の非合法活動と地下鉄サリン事件といったテロ活動を行いました多くの日本人が
犠牲になり世界を震撼させた事件でした
もしこの時
世界の人々が入っ
オウムは日本の仏教系が過激派組織だと言って仏教系の日本人も同じ仲間だと見たとし
たら
皆さんはどう思いますか
全力で否定すると思います
ただこれが is イスラム国のイメージで見られている
イスラム教徒の現状なのです
is の犠牲さの95%が実は一切女教徒であるという事実にもかかわらずです
武は平和という意味です
私たちの挨拶は
アッサラームアレイくん
あなたの上に平安をという意味です
テロや暴力に訴えた主義や主張というのはいすたむでは到底受け入れられるものでは
ありません
これまでの武の話の中で
知っていることや知らないことはあったでしょうか
知らないということは悪いことではありません
ただ
事実を知ることに無関心であったり
イメージで判断したり誤った情報を拡散したりすることは怖いことです
事実や相手を知らないならば私たちは知るべきであり
知る努力をする必要があるのです
今世界はイスラムといっしょ6教に対するネガティブキャンペーンがあらゆる形で行わ
れています
にも関わらずこの生き方を除き
この生き方に
自分の真実を見つける人は少なくないのです
私は
一人の人間として家族として友人としてそしてイスラム教徒として多くの方に受け入れ
られていると感じています
それは
イメージではなく
真実の私を見て
心の中身を見て考えてくれる方が多いからだと思っています
私が
大学生のとき自分の6時に気が付いた時
納得するまで調べてみようと
熱中したことで
イスラムという宝を手に入れました
もし皆さんが
イメージアメディアでしか知らない世界があるとしたらそれはチャンスです
新しい世界を切り開くチャンスです納得するまで世界を見てください
皆さんのたからは自ら
知る努力をした時に手に入るのですから
あっ空まで行くんありがとうございました
[拍手]
[音楽]